speaking of data exploration and awk
uh first what is awk so hawk is a
scripting language that was
done um by myself al aho and peter
weinberger
we did that originally in the late 70s
it was a language that was meant to make
it really easy to do
quick and dirty tasks like counting
things or
selecting interesting information from
basically all text files
rearranging it in some way or
summarizing it
it runs a command on each line or a file
i mean there's uh it's still
exceptionally widely used today
oh absolutely yeah it's so simple and
elegant sort of
the way to explore data turns out you
can just write a script that does
something seemingly trivial on a single
line
and that giving you that slice of the
data somehow reveals something
fundamental about the data
yeah and it keeps that seems to work
still yeah it's very good for that kind
of thing and what's
that's sort of what it was meant for i
think what we didn't appreciate was
that the model was actually quite good
for a lot of data processing kinds of
tasks and that it's it's
kept going as long as it has because at
this point it's over 40 years old and
it's
still i think a useful tool and well
this is paternal interest i guess but i
think in terms of programming languages
you get the most bang for the buck by
learning awk
and it doesn't scale the big programs
but it does pretty
pretty darn well on these little things
where you just want to see all the
somethings in something
and so yeah i find i probably write more
hawk than anything else at this point
uh so what what kind of stuff do you
love about awk like is there
if you can comment on sort of things
uh that give you joy when you can
in a simple program reveals something
about the data is there something that
stands out
from particular features i think it's
mostly the the
selection of default behaviors that you
sort of hinted at a moment ago what oct
does is to read through
a set of files and then within each file
it writes through
each of the lines and then on each of
the lines it has a set of patterns
that it looks for that's your awk
program
and if one of the patterns matches there
is a corresponding action that you might
perform and so it's
kind of a quadruply nested loop or
something like that
and that's all completely automatic you
don't have to say anything about it you
just write the pattern and the action
and then run the data by it and and so
that
paradigm for programming is a very
natural and effective one
and i think we captured that reasonably
well in awk
and it does other things for free as
well it splits the data
into fields so that on each line there
it feels separated by white space or
something and so it does that for free
you don't have to say anything about it
and it collects information as it goes
along like what line are we on how many
fields are there on this line
so lots of things that just make it so
that a program which in
another language let's say python would
be 5 10
20 lines in awk is one or two lines and
so because it's one or two lines you can
do it
on the shell like you don't have to open
up another whole thing you can just do
it right
there in the interaction with the with
the opportunities just correctly
is there other shell commands that you
love over the years like you really
enjoyed using
the major crap
does everything oh so grab is a kind of
a what is it a
simpler version of awk i would say in in
some in some sense yeah right because
what is grep so grep is it basically
searches
the input for particular patterns
regular expressions technically of a
certain class
and it has that same paradigm that ock
does it's a pattern action thing it
reads through all the files
and then all the lines in each file but
it has a single
pattern which is the regular expression
you're looking for and a single action
printed if it matches so it's a in that
sense it's a much simpler version and
you could write
crappy and lock as a one-liner
and i use grep probably more than
anything else
at this point uh just because it it's so
convenient and natural why do you think
it's such a powerful tool
grap noc why do you think operating
systems like windows for example don't
have it sort of you can of course i use
the the which is amazing now there's uh
windows for linux
like which you could basically use
all the fun stuff like all can grab and
inside of windows
but windows naturally sort of in the as
part of the graphical interface the
simplicity of grep
sort of searching through a bunch of
files and just popping up
naturally why don't you think that why
do you think that's unique to the unix
and
linux environment i don't know and it's
not strictly unique but it's certainly
focused there and i think some of it's
the weight of history um
that windows came from ms-dos ms-dos was
a pretty pathetic operating system
although
common on an unboundedly large number of
machines
but somewhere in roughly the 90s
windows became a graphical system and i
think microsoft spent
a lot of their energy on making that
graphical interface
what it is and that's a different model
of computing
it's a model of computing that where you
point and click
and sort of experiment with menus it's a
model computing works
right rather well for people who are not
programmers i just want to get something
done
whereas teaching something like the
command line
to non-programmers turns out to
sometimes be an uphill struggle
and so i think microsoft probably was
right and what they did
now you mentioned whistle or whatever
it's called the winnings
what's that i wonder what's pronounced
wsl is what i've never actually
pronounced the whistle i like it i have
no idea
but there have been things like that for
long cygwin for example which is a
wonderful
collection of take all your favorite
tools from unix and linux and just make
them work perfectly on windows and so
that's a
something that's been going on for at
least 20 years if not
longer and i use that on my one
remaining windows machine
routinely because it it's for if you're
doing something that is batch computing
command suitable for command line uh
that's the right way to do it because
the windows equivalents are
if nothing else not familiar to me
but i should i would definitely
recommend to people to if they don't use
sigmund to try
whistle yes i said i uh i've been so
excited that i could
use bash w bash write scripts quickly in
in windows it's
changed my my life okay
you